[Musique]
bonjour éric bouchard merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté ce matin notre
invitation sur rt france le taux de
contamination est trois fois supérieur
le taux d'incidence est trois fois et
demi supérieur à la moyenne nationale
est ce que vous partagez le cri d'alarmé
du maire de nice christian estrosi alors
bonjour oui oui non c'est à dire
qu'effectivement ce que je représente
quand même la médecine libérale dans le
département et la région paca il ya les
qu'il était plus forte
la difficulté qu'on a surtout si les
auspices les hôpitaux puisque c'est le
qui sont quand même un petit peu débordé
je dirais qu'un grand confinement
maintenant le jeune loup j'allais
beaucoup je pense qu'il faut s'appuyer
plus sur la médecine libérale
c'est vrai qu'il ya département des
alpes-maritimes pour des raisons encore
inexpliquées mais dont on n'a pas une
certitude absolue est en difficulté en
matière de contamination qui est assez
surprenante
vous êtes ne pas vouloir de confinement
on s'attend un confinement sur le
littoral le week end une revue des
jauges notamment de clients accepté dans
les magasins qu'attendez-vous de la
conférence de presse du préfet des
alpes-maritimes à la mi-journée ce qu'on
attendrait surtout c'est de savoir un
petit peu la raison pour laquelle pas
exactement qui m'a particulièrement un
peu comme en moselle
je dirais on a ce toute contamination
c'est vrai que nous qui sommes sur le
terrain et nous les médecins libéraux
on se rend bien compte que les mesures
barrières ne sont pas bien appliquées
mal appliquée l'exemple était dans votre
reportage vous aviez quelqu'un qui
parlait avec le masque sous le nez ce
qui est ce que l'on reprises en plus
peut-être qu'il faudrait d'abord ce
revenir sur des mesures barrières et les
faire appliquer ça serait déjà à travers
ce sens après on va attendre
je suis comme vous je ne sais pas très
bien ce que le préfet va décider ou
plutôt que ce que l'état va décider
puisque même si on donne gtl à me
reprocher ça reste quand même le
ministre le gouvernement qui décide ce
qu'il faudrait c'est davantage analysé
les raisons de cette poussée de la
contamination
je pense que c'est la première chose
c'est dire que pour faire un bon
diagnostic yves nous avons fait rare il
faut faire un bon diagnostic
- avoir des bases 1 pourquoi avons-nous
nous cette explosion des contaminations
à partir de là on peut réellement faire
quelque chose si nous n'avons pas je
dirais un diagnostic précis avec les
analyses des causes c'est très difficile
de prendre des mesures intelligentes le
littoral mais certains niçois disent
aussi que les les zones à problème sont
aussi dans les quartiers populaires de
nice est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec
ça vous qui êtes sur le terrain
alors si le sentiment qu'on en a mais
c'est pas une certitude non plus c'est
qu'on a en tout cas à mon niveau je n'ai
pas suffisamment d'éléments je dirais
pour pour dire c'est simple ces passages
je crois qu'elle est mesures qui sont
faites dans les eaux usées je pense que
c'est peut-être au préfet à
l'administration de dire voilà dans
certains quartiers il ya des
problématiques et peut-être accès
fortement je lirai la prévention les
gestes barrières sur ces quartiers
maintenant je n'ai pas suffisamment
d'éléments pour m'avancer
certains appellent aussi aux touristes
français évidemment puisque c'est les
vacances à nice de ne pas venir sur la
côte d'azur ça vous paraît demain de la
solution salut il ya d'autres zones qui
en france qui ont des tourisme on parle
de la bretagne de la côte atlantique des
stations de ski
mais actuellement il n'y a pas pour
autant que je dirais une augmentation
énorme jeu des raids et des cas donc je
pense que c'est pas l'unique raison
alors olivier ferrand s'est déplacé
personnellement à nice ce week end
il a promis une dotation de 3500 vaccin
ça ça serait une solution selon vous la
vaccination les médecins généralistes
d'ailleurs vont pouvoir accéder à partir
de jeudi est en principe c'est
exactement la vaccination est
probablement la solution mais pas de
court terme
d'abord trois de 3500 vaccins
supplémentaires pour lequel peu son
département qui est quand même vous dire
quelque chose comme 20 millions de
personnes
singh au dos dans la problématique des
climatisations
ou est-ce qu'on en est d'ailleurs de la
vaccination dans les alpes-maritimes
jusqu'ici ça fonctionne ça fonctionne en
fonction des dotations des vaccins le
problème le problème n'est pas de
vacciner les gens c'est devant le
produit pour roxy et ses missions
revient
généraliste 1 qui vont vacciner ou les
libéraux vous avez droit actuellement un
réflexe qu'on l'a cette semaine par
cabinet médical à 2 10 doses donc la
semaine suivante normalement ça devrait
augmenter le débat n'est pas de vacciner
les gens c'est d'avoir quelque chose
pour les vacciner avant d'être un flacon
de neydens par semaine
effectivement ces apports oui c'est très
peu ça vous fait donc ça fait 10
patience si vous avez en france auger
statistique française a je ne les ai pas
au niveau du département
nous n'avons pas ils remonter dessus en
france qui a mis généralistes qui sont
déjà inscrits pour eux auprès des
pharmacies pour obtenir donc ce vaccin
c'est flacons de vaccin dino
d'astrazeneca savatier à 210 personnes
c'est dans le meilleur des cas c'est une
semaine et c'est votre cas vous avez
vous êtes inscrit voici pourra recevoir
ces gosses vous êtes mon épouse qui est
médecin est inscrit et oui le cabinet
médical féline et ses soeurs parlons de
la saturation des hôpitaux c'est ce qui
pose problème à nice et dans les
alentours que constatez-vous évidemment
de cette situation il ya eu des
transferts de patients d'hôpitaux à
d'autres hôpitaux autour de nice alors
oui et commencer à voir des transferts
en tout cas c'est ce qui est cédée
renseignements qu'on en a après je pense
que il faut absolument que les hôpitaux
s'appuie sur les cliniques privées sur
le privé pour réussir à prendre en
charge les patients
après on est sur un problème qui est un
problème structurel depuis maintenant la
loi hpst 2010 d'une part il ya eu la
mainmise de l'administration de la
technostructure sur les hôpitaux ce qui
n'a rien arrangé mais parce que c'était
le principe de la loi hpst de 2010 avec
la création des ars
je ne suis pas sûr qu'on va toujours
c'est tout pareil chaque fois qu'il ya
des astres quelque part ou une crise on
se rend compte d incompétence au désert
des insuffisances de mots de ce que l'on
a fait dans les années précédentes ça
marche est relativement à peu près
correctement en temps normal maintenant
on voit bien qu'un problème donc je
pense qu'il faut revoir d'une part la
guerre et de la dgs et la direction des
hôpitaux à cet évident il faut réfléchir
d'autre part
à peut-être améliorer comme les seuls à
la taille des services de réanimation je
pense que c'est un des problèmes 206 on
a lui mis le mi6 de plus je dirais dans
les hôpitaux on serait certainement pas
danser la situation de calais n'est
actuellement en tout cas à se poser les
mêmes problèmes traitements alternatifs
aux vaccins en sel ont suscité pas mal
de polémiques et qu'est-ce qu'ils sont
toujours employés alors nous chez je
vais parler de la médecine libérale
puisque je peux difficilement parler des
services hospitaliers c'est pas mon rôle
non plus c'est vrai que on a du mal on a
du mal à avoir des certitudes
scientifiques sur les différents
traitements alors il ya pas vraiment on
a l'impression qu'ils les américains
s'en sort avec le traitement de donald
trump
il ya des choses qui sont qui existent
mais qui sont quand même relativement
cher et qui ne sont pas utilisables en
train de quitter alors après il ya des
équipes sur le coccyx in actuellement
j'étais je ne suis pas un spécialiste
donc j'aurais du mal à vous en dire plus
ils voulaient préconisé ces traitements
alternatifs et toi non non pas
particulièrement
soul et il est difficile pour un médecin
ne pas s'appuyer sur des recommandations
scientifiques réelle et certaine
et donc titre personnel non merci
beaucoup et éric bouchard d'avoir
répondu ce matin en direct à nos
questions sur arte france